le 31e conseil des ministres de la
commission de l'océan indien s'est tenue
ces derniers jours dans notre île
un conseil des ministres qui s'est tenu
en présence du secrétaire d'état chargé
du développement et de la francophonie
c'est devant un parterre de ministres
venus de la zone de parlementaires et
des présidents des collectivités locales
que la représentante de madagascar a
remis officiellement le drapeau de la
cia la france c'est donc confiant de
malagar train passe le flambeau de la
présidence de l'organisation à la france
je vous reverrai ce drapeau symbole de
notre organisation pour que vous
puissiez porté au plus haut et plus loin
il ya beaucoup de défis à faire sur
l'océan indien
comme je le dis souvent et que je mette
fois nous
ddd francs auprès des deux îles soeurs
cette libre circulation entre les îles
de l'océan indien on puisse se font du
lèche de voyager sans pro sans trop de
problèmes de visa par exemple il ya
aussi d'interconnexion aujourd'hui et à
sept îles vanille qu'on a pu signer
ensemble
ça il ya d'autres défis qu'on espère que
la présidence française des soeurs
continuer madagascar qui sort de cette
présidence avec un bilan très positif
notamment en matière de lutte contre la
piraterie avec la mise en place d'une
fusion entre les centres maritimes qui a
permis un échange d'information lci où
il ya aussi gagner en visibilité sur le
plan international et régional mais
néanmoins beaucoup de défis restent
encore à relever la france va donner à
sa présidence trois orientations
majeures la sécurité bien sûr d'abord la
sécurité le terrorisme djihadiste frappe
partout maintenant dans le monde en
europe bien sûr à paris les attentats de
paris sont dans toutes les mémoires mais
aussi en afrique du nord en afrique
sahélienne en afrique de l'est
il faut être vigilant il faut que la
garde soit maximale et que les moyens
soient donnés aux états bien sûr par eux
mêmes mais aussi en coopérant entre eux
ici dans l'océan indien les moyens sont
donnés pour assurer la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de nos institutions
car le terrorisme djihadiste vise bien
sûr à actu est évidemment mais à
déstabiliser aussi nos institutions
démocratiques donc soyons vigion soyons
intraitables avec la lutte que nous
devons mener contre le terrorisme ici
aussi dans l'océan indien
pour le secrétaire général qui quitte
également son poste l'heure du bilan est
venu et ce bilan est plus que
satisfaisant
outre la lutte contre la piraterie il
retient aussi une meilleure connectivité
dans plusieurs domaines et nous avons
avancé sur un très large éventail de ce
matin et on a parlé en particulier ce
sont les questions de connectivité
il existe aujourd'hui une alliance
vanille qui regroupe les transporteurs
rien de la région et qui cherche à
améliorer la connectivité intérim nous
avons parlé ce matin de la connectivité
maritime de manière à améliorer les
échanges dans notre pays qui reste
extrêmement faible
alors que nous avons échangé nous avons
parlé ce matin aussi de la connectivité
numérique ce que nous sommes en train de
travailler sur un projet de
l'installation d'un troisième câble de
fibre optique de manière à améliorer la
connectivité red rat série une
coopération régionale partagé entre les
deux collectivités de la réunion pour la
région il s'agit bien sûr de faciliter
encore plus les déplacements notamment
aériens dans la zone océan indien
évidemment pas ses enfants l'apéritif
présidence française doit permettre de
marquer un tournant celui peut-être de
prendre davantage en considération des
collectivités locales département région
parce que nous sommes peut-être sur le
champ notamment du développement
économique
parmi les premiers acteurs novès qui se
doit se faire en matière de coopération
décentralisée
ça c'est un premier volet en premier
aspect le deuxième c'est de faire en
sorte que nous considérons bien que le
développement de la réunion passe par
notre capacité à être ouvert au monde à
travailler avec les autres aux îles de
l'océan indien et à le faire aussi en
pensant aux grands pays du grand océan
indien
je fais référence en disant c est bien
sûr au pays de l'est africain
alain ou encore
à lachine et puis troisième volet ça
celui de mieux assurer les relations les
collections entre les différentes îles
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui conseil régional nous
travaillons sur un projet de compagnie
low cost de l'océan indien
donc permettre aux populations de
pouvoir voyager d'une île à l'autre
un des tarifs beaucoup plus intéressant
que ce que nous connaissons pour
nassimah dindar présidente du conseil
départemental beaucoup de progrès ont
été accomplis mais pour encore plus
d'efficience il faut mettre en place une
coordination pour faciliter les échanges
notamment entre l'état et les
collectivités locales
aujourd'hui avec région sur le
développement des échanges aériens et
macquarie sur la sécurité alimentaire
je crois que nous avons lancé des voies
d'avenir de la croissance que nous
puissions travailler ensemble il est
impératif malgré tout qu'il y ait au
niveau des instances
et à une représentation du ministère des
affaires étrangères une coordination
nécessaire avec les collectivités
territoriales
asteur également de la coopération au
travers les fonds européens que nous
et que nous gérons
le fait d a principalement pour la
région réunion et et nous les mesures
également avec un t1 3 qui offre des
possibilités donc de grandes ambitions
les représentants de la commission océan
indien se sont ensuite retrouvés à
l'invitation des deux collectivités dans
les jardins de la villa du département
pour clore ce 31e conseil des ministres
un moment de convivialité qui a permis
de poursuivre les échanges et de poser
les jalons de cette présidence française